you would hardly notice it if you drove
by but this warehouse near downtown
ottawa
houses nothing less than the very
machinery of canada's democracy
forms manuals ballots
all that is needed to record the
political preferences of up to 19
million voters
in 338 ridings but the work here these
days
is different the pandemic changes
everything
and it forced elections canada to
rethink the entire process of
sending canadians to the polls
natasha gautier speaks for elections
canada and for more than a year
she and her colleagues have been focused
on one thing
to make sure that if there is an
election we are able to deliver an
election that is as
safe as possible for voters
for election canada's staff for poll
workers because that's also a priority
for us
and to make sure that we are able to do
that in a way that the integrity of the
election
is not compromised in any way it starts
with
safety elections canada has made a huge
buy of ppe
and it's all here waiting to be shipped
to hundreds of polling stations
19 million surgical masks gloves
hand sanitizer half a million face
shields
plexiglas barriers and then there's the
pencils
in a pandemic election no pencil will be
used
twice so elections canada has purchased
lots of single-use pencils 16 million of
them
the pencil is vital because for all of
our history
this is the way we've picked our
politicians a piece of paper
a pencil and an ex that's how people
will vote in the next general election
even if it's held in a time of pandemic
there won't be any e-voting no digital
ballots no using an iphone to cast an x
it will be pencil and paper but there
may be a change to
where and when you use that pencil and
paper because
here at elections canada they believe
that as many as five million people
will vote by mail if we have an election
in a pandemic
and in 2019 in the last election just
fifty four thousand voted by mail
but now this year that could be five
million
how about another number we need only
look to the provincial pandemic
elections in british columbia
saskatchewan new brunswick
newfoundland and labrador and of course
to the u.s presidential election to see
how the pandemic
changed the way voters pick their
politicians how politicians pick their
voters
and how officials make sure it's all
done fairly and accurately
bob doer ran the winning ndp war room
for the bc provincial election last fall
we were extremely nervous because
there's no playbook on this
there's there's no playbook on how you
run a pandemic campaign
pollster dimitri pantazopoulos was
inside the losing war room with the bc
liberals
there are no big rallies there's you
know it makes it very difficult to
generate momentum
the big difference how each of those
campaigns dealt with
mail-in ballots when we identified
people that were going to vote for us
to make sure that they were able to
register to get a mail-in ballot that
was their first objective
the second objective once they got the
mail-in ballot
was to how to fill it out people a lot
of people have never done this before
the mail out ballot is a little bit of a
different uh a different
species you know first of all
encouraging people to actually
get their ballot and then secondly
focusing on how to get them to return it
the ndp literally had to show its
digital first
millennial supporters how to work an
envelope
a lot of people were not uh we're not
used to going and
seeing that red box at the end of their
uh at the end of the street and putting
a
mail in there and voila it goes
somewhere i've written in
the name of who i want to vote for in a
federal pandemic election
expect parties to spend a lot of time
teaching supporters
how to use the mail-in ballot so this is
the package
so this is the package this is what we
call a
special ballot kit so each envelope will
have a number
and while asking for a mail-in ballot
will be done online
everything else is all analog paper
pencil and the old-fashioned mail system
voters will have to follow the
instructions that come with the ballot
or risk their ballot getting thrown out
each ballot
envelope will be open by hand one by one
no machines and each will be counted by
at least two
poll workers again no machines people
should be prepared to expect delays in
the results
and we may not know the final results of
the election on election night
while the act of voting and counting the
votes is a paper-based
human activity with almost no machines
involved
it will be just the opposite for the act
of campaigning
the smartphone will play a starring role
in a pandemic election
it really changes how you're able to
to to find people and actually also get
them out to vote
using technology to connect voters to
politicians
has been a growing trend for decades
it's a trend university of guelph
political scientist
tamara small has been studying she says
more technology means voters will get an
individualized experience
algorithms will slice and dice
demographic data putting voters into
smaller and smaller groups and
that changes the democratic process
this idea of a one-on-one campaign why i
think it's seductive i also think
there's some real democratic issues that
we have to
sort of think through voters may not
even be aware of the pitches
a campaign is making to other kinds of
voters i actually don't know whether or
not
my instagram ads are the same as my
neighbor's instagram ad
and probably they're not and in any
event an
old digital campaign may leave some
voters behind
it's easy to think that technology is
easy it's evenly distributed to
everybody it's just not
and so therefore some people are not
going to have the same sort of campaign
as other people might
political rallies coffee shop arguments
door step
discussions all of that disappears in a
pandemic election
we did not allow volunteers into our
campaign office it was just paid staff
and we did no door-to-door canvassing
two big things that we've never done
before
and that lack of social interaction with
campaigners with other voters
is likely to result in lower voter
turnout
it's interesting to have people come to
your door that's a good thing that that
usually gets people out to vote
and we're to lose a number of those
things low voter turnout high voter
turnout
elections canada is ready for all
scenarios
i'm very proud of the work that my
colleagues have done
and when the 44th general election is
all over
all the millions of ballots cast mail in
or otherwise
we'll come back here back to the
warehouse at elections canada
to be stored for 10 years one
final safeguard against challenges a
complete
paper record of the pandemic election